Aw Yeah! I'm back with another fun English lesson
with Disney movies. This time with the 2000
classic, Monsters Inc! So Disney-Pixar movies like
Monsters Inc. are perfect for learning English
vocabulary and expressions, plus the characters
usually have very clear and native pronunciation.
Now, we're about to show you the clip that
we've chosen for you today but before we do,
I wanted to let you know that every week we
make new lessons like this one so that you can
understand fast-speaking natives without
getting lost, without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles! Like Parisa, who says
that after every lesson, she's feeling her
English progressing! So if you want to learn
a ton and have a lot of fun too, all you have
to do is hit that subscribe button and the bell
down bellow to not miss any of our new lessons!
Hey, real quick! Do you want to master native
pronunciation, vocabulary, and even grammar?
Well, the most fun way to do it is with our Fluent
with Friends course! And today you can try it
for FREE with our 3-part Masterclass!
So I want to give you three reasons why you
should try out this 3-part Masterclass. The
first one is vocabulary you will learn tons of
vocabulary. And not just vocabulary that you
never use and you forget, but the vocabulary
that natives really use every single day. And it
will also show you how to never forget it.
The second reason is because of pronunciation — you
will learn the way that natives really speak,
not at all like how you learned in school.
And the third reason is because you will
learn the cultural context, so that you'll
be able to understand, and laugh along with
every single joke. And in addition to all of
this, if you join our full Fluent with Friends
course you will never be alone in your learning,
because you get to join our global community of
English learners, the Fluency Circle. So what
are you waiting for? You can try that all for
FREE with our 3-part Masterclass by
clicking up here or down description below.